Why don't you trust me? Right? Something
that we might say to somebody or you
might say the reverse is like, "Just
trust me." And that word, people have a
very hard time of knowing like, "What
the hell does that even mean? What does
trust even mean?" And so, this is a
departure from my normal business
content, but I think you will like it,
or at least I do. And so, I was thinking
about this because someone recently was
like, "Hey, trust me." And I was like,
"Huh, that's an odd command. What does
that even mean?" And so, I want to break
down number one, what does trust
actually mean from a behavior
perspective? How can I look at someone
and say trust has occurred here? Right?
And then, are there different types of
trust? So that, which is what confuses
this whole thing because there isn't
just one, there's actually four. And
this is after actually thinking about
this one statement that a friend made to
me. And so, the four types of trust
actually correspond with two big
variables, which is who's at risk and
who does the punishing. So, woah, woah,
slow down. So, you're saying trust is
about punishment? The answer is yes. So,
if I trust someone, it means that I make
myself punishable by them. So, for
example, if I say, "I'm going to share a
secret with you," then it means I give
you something that you can punish me
with. And the idea is that I believe I'm
making a bet that you're not going to
punish me. And that's the risk, right?
And so, the idea is we have you who are
at risk, so you risk.
And then, we have the other person uh
punishing, right?
That's the first type. The second type
of risk is that someone else
does the risking with you, and they say,
"I'm going to give you a secret. I'm
going to give you a knife and you can
point it at my back, and I'm going to
bet that you're not going to stab." All
right? So, now you're the one who can
punish them. That means that you are
being trustworthy to them. I'm going to
give you prescriptions on how to
actually do this because this has been
so helpful for thinking about this
through like a relationship. Like,
imagine Layla and I were married, and I
want her to trust me more, and she wants
me to trust her. So, it's like, how can
we actually prescribe, do these things
to gain trust? And this is what I want
to talk about, and that's what we're
we're to do. All right? Let me just
cover the other two. So, if you're at
risk, who else is the possible punisher?
Well, it's the environment. So, that
means that reality punishes you. So,
what does that actually look like? That
would be
"Hey, can I trust you to pick my kid up
tomorrow?" Right? Sure.
How would that happen? Well, I'm going
to give them something, two different
things, that I that I value a lot. They
could punish me. They could kidnap my
kid. That would suck, right? Or they
could not pick up my kid, also would
suck. Are they the one doing the
punishing? Well, kidnapping, yes. But,
if they just didn't keep their word and
just didn't pick the kid up, the
environment would do the punishing,
right? Now, to the same degree, someone
can trust me, and it can't just doesn't
always have to be about action, like me
doing something for someone else. It can
also be about advice. So, if I'm like,
"Man, I really trust her. I trust her
advice. She has good insight." Right?
Then, I might follow that advice, and a
bad thing would happen, and then I'd be
like, "I don't trust her that much. She
gives terrible advice." Right? And so,
these are the four conditions. So, you
basically have
secrets or information, right? That
someone can give you, or someone or you
can give someone, that they can use and
hurt you. Or, you give someone your word
that you're going to do something,
either make it happen, or that they
should do it. And in either of those
scenarios, the environment does the
punishing. All right? Here's the
thinking process around, "Should I do
this?" So, two questions.
Number one, do they have a track record
of protecting what they've been given,
the things and information that you've
given to them, right? Have they had a
knife before pointed at your back and
not used it?
And,
does burning you cost them more than
protecting you? AKA, is betraying you a
bad deal for them?
And so, if both of those scenarios,
meaning they gain more from protecting
you, number one, and number two, they
have a track record of not burning you,
then it makes sense to go forward with
the trust. Now, why would you trust to
begin with if we define trust as
allowing yourself to be punishable?
Because the ceiling of a relationship
potential is based on the shared context
that both people have about each other.
If I had a stranger as the completely
opposite extreme, there's a limit to how
much I can help someone if I don't know
anything about them. And so, every
single thing that we volunteer about
ourselves gives the other person
context. Now, the more someone knows
about you, the more they can hurt you,
right? And so, the idea is a perfectly
trusting relationship would allow both
people to best serve one another. The
difficulty is that humans often times
have short-term incentives that are
adverse to their long-term goals. I'll
give you an example. So, if I trust my
wife and I say, "You know, I don't like
my mother." I'm making this up, all
right?
And later, in a fight, my wife uses what
I told her about my mother, and it could
be tomorrow or it could be 6 months from
now. If she uses that against me, then
I'm going to be way less likely to trust
her again. But, it means that the
calculus that my wife has to make in the
moment when I've given her something
valuable is that she has to say, "Me
winning this argument in the short term
is not worth the cost of losing the
relationship." And so, what's really
difficult about trust is trust, almost
more than anything else, is based on
zero punishment. So, what does that
mean? So, it means that you give someone
a little bit of thing and they don't do
anything bad with it. You give them a
little bit more, don't do anything bad.
You give them a little bit more, you
give them a little bit more. And then,
eventually, the the incentive for them
is so high to wrong you that they do.
And that sucks.
And so, when they do that one time, and
people I mean, think about Think about
the relationships, the marriages where
it's like, "I trusted him for 20 years."
You know, and then like, "Boom, he did
that one thing, and that was it. Could
never trust him again." Right? It's
because the punishing event of betraying
someone will literally undo all the
reward and reinforcement cycles you did
beforehand. Which is why if you want to
be trustworthy, you have to do zero
punishment. And that means both at when
they disclose the thing, someone says,
"Hey, I'm coming out of the closet. I'm
gay now." The moment they give you the
thing for sure is a reinforcing event to
make sure that you not only want to be
neutral, but like, "Thanks for sharing
that. Your secret's safe with me. It's
your news. Whatever you want me to do
with it, I'll do with it. All right? The
second thing is that it doesn't get used
in the future against them. So, not like
necessarily talking to them, but like if
you share it with somebody else, and
then that person hurts them, they still
don't trust you and won't want to trust
you, and then you get a reputation of
somebody who's loose lips Loose lips
sink ships, right? And so, if you want
people to trust you,
and you want to trust them,
then you need to make sure that they are
trustworthy, which means have they
followed the prescription of becoming
trustworthy now or just online? And this
The reason that I think you have to do
it with every time you share something,
especially if it's material. Obviously,
you're not calculating every single
decision, right? But when it's a
material thing, calculating it
independently and thinking, wait, if I
give this thing, the incentive is way
too big. Like, what do I gain from this
versus what do I risk? And
fundamentally, this is Some people see
this and think, oh, this is just so
transactional. And I think I think
you're wrong, and I think you're dumb.
I'll be really honest with you. Um
we all make this appraisal of plusses
and minuses in our minds on some level.
I'm just trying to clearly define it so
that I can recognize when I'm like, I
don't trust this guy. I can actually
ascribe a filter being like, why don't I
trust him? Oh, when did I make myself
punishable that he used against me? Oh,
in these specific scenarios. And then
that way, when the person's like, why
don't you trust me? It's like, well,
here's four reasons. I told you this,
and then you used it this way. I told
you this, and you used it this way. And
so, the equal opposite is like, I want
to be a trustworthy person because
gaining trust with other people gives
you a lot of stuff. So, number one is it
makes you more influential. If you have
trust, you haven't used anything that
someone else has said to hurt them, then
they will trust you with more things,
which means that your ability have
contacts on them is higher. Number two,
if they trust your advice, the other
type of trust, and they follow your
prescriptions, and good things happen,
the likely they follow the future
prescriptions goes up.
If you say, I'm going to pick up the
kid, and then you do, the likely that
they'll trust you pick up the kid in the
future goes up, which also means that we
have to keep our word. And so, whenever
you have the opportunity to break your
word, that is at a short-term benefit to
you,
realize that you do not harm the
relationship, you likely end it. It just
doesn't die immediately. It's kind of
like cutting a tree off the vine. The
tree's still there for a long time, and
sometimes there's a hollowed-out dead
tree on the inside. It's still there
visibly, but we all know it's dead on
the inside. The The The stream of
nutrients, which we can see truth as
nutrients in a relationship, it gets cut
off the moment someone betrays somebody
else. And so,
I would use this frame, and I'm using
this now, cuz I'm giving a presentation
tomorrow to my company, um sharing
something that that's that they could
use to hurt me,
but I'm trusting them by making myself
punishable, which gives everyone else in
the business the opportunity to earn
more of my trust. Which, to be fair,
I've already given it to them. It's
really theirs to lose.
Real quick, I'm going to show you the
exact 10-stage road map from zero to a
hundred million plus that less than 1%
of companies finish I've now done
multiple times, and so I can say with a
lot of confidence that these are the
stages, as head count increases, that
you need to get through. And I broke
each of these down by eight different
functions of the business, what the
constraint feels like, like what are the
symptoms of it when you're going through
it, and then what steps we actually took
to graduate. And we've done this across
software, physical products, uh service
businesses, brick and mortar, all of
this, and it works. And it's my gift to
you. It's absolutely free. And so, the
link's in the description, but you just
go acquisition.com/roadmap,
enter your info, and it'll spit it right
back to you all for free.